pulverschnee und blauer himmel
riesenstimmung weil er hüttengaudi
massen anfragen anfangen heraus
mittendrin vier arbeitskollegen aus
bochum auf kurztrip einer von ihnen der
programmierer thomas h neun tage nach
seiner heimkehr wird er am corona virus
sterben
der 55 jährige hinterlässt frau und so
fühlte sich kränklich hatte erhöhte
temperatur und meinte dann wir gucken
mal dass ein bisschen auf abstand gehen
dann hat er die nächsten drei tage
lieber kommen 96 39 8 rettungsdienst am
dienstag hat nach drei tagen auf der
intensivstation der bochumer
bergmannsheil klinik stirbt er am 20
märz alleine ohne frau und sohn nicht
und ja er ist dann auch ins
leichenschauhaus gebracht worden
sehen aufgrund der infektion zur selben
zeit wie thomas h war auch jürgen becker
mit seinen freunden aus dem rheinland in
ischgl auch sie infizierten sich dort
und mussten zu hause in quarantäne im
nachhinein wissen wir alle daten wieder
verarscht worden sind und wir sind auch
leider weder vom hotel oder sonst
nirgendwo auch im leisten unterrichtet
worden
wir haben eine freiheitsberaubung von
hat uns hier 14 tage in eine quarantäne
gesteckt wir wollten nur wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen kohle machen
partyspaß in ischgl ein protokoll des
versagens hürth bei köln dritter märz
kurz vor dem skiurlaub informiert sich
jürgen becker im internet über die
verbreitung von corona doch das virus
scheint weit weg
wir haben aber von keinem irgendwie eine
auskunft bekommen dass ich jetzt ein
risikogebiet war dennoch ende februar
hat der tiroler regierungschef günther
platter alle bedenken zerstreut
es wird professionell und verlässlich
gearbeitet darauf kann sich die
bevölkerung verlassen es besteht kein
grund zur beunruhigung island fünfter
märz krankenhaus reykjavik acht urlauber
werden positiv getestet auf gut 19 die
polizei warnt vor der internationalen
presse
wir haben arkona viele spiele in
österreich
darüber sind wir besorgt weil es eine
gruppen infektion ist das land tirol
behauptet die isländer hätten sich beim
rückflug im flugzeug angesteckt weil
auch urlauber aus italien an bord
gewesen sein
doch island deklariert ist jetzt als
risikogebiet amsterdam sechster märz
eine niederländerin erfährt von der
warnung aus island vor der geplanten
ischgl reise schreibt sie an behörden in
tirol
sie sei geschockt wirklich geschockt
dass in österreich niemand warnt vor dem
risiko in ischgl skills tourismusverband
wiegelt ab die behörden in österreich
haben die situation sehr gut unter
kontrolle
genauso wie das land tirol das
robert-koch-institut hat ist nicht als
risikogebiet eingeordnet die empörte
niederländerin erwidert wirtschaftliche
interessen sind wichtiger als unsere
gesundheit schämen sie sich
die frau cancelled den urlaub und bleibt
gesund ist siebter märz das erste video
der rheinländer auf der piste und dann
im prallen party
[Musik]
[Applaus]
laut feuchtfröhlich natürlich ohne
abstand und alles ohne jede corona
warnung an die gäste so erzählt es auch
die witwe von thomas hart nein gar nicht
zu einer warnung war nie die rede
sie sehen da die dollar zeichen und der
ich bekenne das ist ballermann und
rosenmontag zusammen
da wird abgefeiert party gemacht und ja
da geht man ja über in
anführungsstrichen reichen denn an
diesem samstag geben die behörden
bekannt dass hier in der apres ski
pakets noch ein barkeeper mit corona
infiziert ist wahrscheinlich hat er
viele gäste angesteckt im kids noch hat
niemand die korona warnung ernst
genommen räumt der wirte inzwischen
selbst infiziert ist heute ein dass ich
ihm dass er so läuft das dass wir uns
gegenseitig anstecken und das wolle
klebte wellig und dadurch ich das
eigentlich nicht so schnell erkennbar
gewesen dass es sich wirklich um den
währungshandel und auch am 8 märz immer
noch party im kiez noch obwohl die
behörden weiteres personal auf corona
testen das land tirol aber verharmlost
auf seiner facebook seite immer noch das
ansteckungsrisiko durch den 36 jährigen
norweger der in wirklichkeit ein
deutscher ist für alle besucher innen
die im besagten zeitraum in der bar
waren und keine symptome aufweisen ist
keine weitere medizinische abklärungen
nötig ich denke das war keine gute idee
ich glaube es wäre wichtig gewesen klar
zu kommunizieren
da war ein infizierter es könnte sein
dass sie sich angesteckt haben
und dass man klare vorgaben macht die
still neunter märz es wird immer noch
gefeiert im kids loch obwohl jetzt
bekannt ist
dass sie hier 15 kollegen des barkeepers
ebenfalls infiziert haben
jetzt schaltet sich ein mächtiger mann
ein peter franzl ich bin zillertaler
tiroler dort tourismusunternehmer und
bauer und der sitz im österreichischen
nationalrat für die svp der
wirtschaftslobby ist schreibt am 9 märz
an die familie der kids noch betreiber
zwei sms sperren kids bar zu oder willst
du schuld am ende der saison sein wenn
eine kamera die im betrieb sieht stehen
wir tiroler da wie ein hottentotten
start erst am späten abend des 9
märz wird das kitz loch von den behörden
geschlossen in den übrigen darf aber ist
weiter halli galli in der champagne
hütte wurde ganz klar gesagt es geht
weiter also überhaupt nicht man braucht
keine sorgen zu machen es geht weiter an
wanted wollte diesen ganzen zirkus der
und das passt alle sind in ischgl
stattfindet die ganzen partys das ganze
geld was dort verdient wird nicht in
gefahr bringen und hatte gehofft dass
das irgendwie so nicht gemerkt wird der
zehnte merten ist für die herren gruppe
aus dem rheinland sind ihre
urlaubsfreuden blauer himmel
gleich nebenan hat nichts auszusetzen
außer der dazu voll ist
wir haben samstag sonntag montag ja
überall auf den nachtbus ski gefahren
wie mit kennt und nachmittags dann ab in
die hütten und da die tausende leute die
da überall standen und auch gefeiert
haben
auch im ort selber da hat keiner das
wort gerona irgendwo in den mund
genommen also der après ski lief dann
noch den dienstag voll im gange also
doch zwischen 9 und 10 uhr abends
ungefähr und da wurde uns ja auch zum
schluss gesagt jungs drängt das letzte
bier aus wir machen in einer stunde die
ich gelernt dass abschiedsfoto der
rheinländer auf dem heimweg haben alle
kratzen im hals
von den insgesamt 16 männern aus hört
und kärnten haben sich 14 mit corona
infiziert und wir haben leider dort ist
teilweise dann auch noch unsere frauen
damit infiziert schwerste erkrankungen
durch den ansteckungskette ungehinderte
ausbreitung die 20 fälle im rheinland in
hamburg 80 24 fälle im schwäbischen
aalen 6 in gütersloh 8
in dresden weitere ist locker in
rheinland pfalz hessen baden württemberg
und bayern über europa hinweg nach
island norwegen schweden dänemark
großbritannien und nach irland schleppen
ist die urlauber das virus und stecken
hunderte menschen an dreizehnter märz
endlich shutdown in ischgl die
saisonkräfte sollen das dorf sofort
verlassen obwohl keiner weiß ob er
infiziert ist trotzdem habe jeder ein
gesundheitszertifikat bekommen behauptet
steve elle visp koch aus berlin im
österreichischen rundfunk gefahren bin
standen hunderte leute beim rat wollten
sich alle testen lassen dass die
bestätigung vom arzt und haus steht der
geehrte damen und herren aber es wurde
nichts gemacht mir wurde nur ein
fieberthermometer damit ohr gesteckt
fertig um genannte person erfreut sich
bester gesundheit und es gab keinen
kontakt mit sowie 19 positiv getesteten
personen der orf stellt ihr stück dorf
hat walser zur rede
da bin ich es mir kalt sagte grath die
ausgestellte und west die leute keinen
kontakt gehabt haben
der stellenwert der ecke gekommen ob sie
gesund sind und das dass sie keine krone
kommt aus gestimmt trotzdem in diesem
ärztlichen attest heißt es kein kontakt
mit 19 patienten auch in diesem fall ist
die staatsanwaltschaft innsbruck jetzt
gefordert denn bisher prüft sie nur den
anfangsverdacht dass behörden versagen
der einschlägige straftatbestand wegen
denen wir wickeln würden wenn ein
anfangsverdacht da ist dies dem die
gefährdung von menschen durch
übertragbare krankheiten ist ja da
bestand ist dann erfüllt wenn jemand
etwas tut oder etwas unterlässt
verpflichtet wäre und dadurch andere
durch diese krankheit gefällt diese
gefährdung anderer durch übertragbare
krankheiten kann einerseits vorsätzlich
und andererseits fahrlässig begangen
werden beim vorsätzlichen liegt beträgt
die strafdrohung bis zu drei jahre
freiheitsstrafe
bei einer fahrlässigen begehung droht
geldstrafe oder eine freiheitsstrafe bis
zu einem jahr
wir bitten die behörden in österreich
vergeblich um interviews sie antworten
nur schriftlich skills bürgermeister
werner kurz schiebt die verantwortung
dem land tirol zu zitat
die gemeinde gespielt war in die
entscheidungsprozesse nicht involviert
für tirol äußert sich
gesundheitslandesrat bernhard tilg im
österreichischen rundfunk die
vorgangsweise der behörde war
grundsätzlich richtig und haut dann zur
schließung des apollo kreis geführt da
sagen jetzt sehr viele menschen da hat
sich in tirol einfach die extrem
einflussreiche bergbahn und tourismus
lobby gegen die medizinische vernunft
durchgesetzt
nein ich denke das stimmt nicht seit
drei wochen haben wir stündlich und
täglich maßnahmen getroffen glaube die
behörden haben wir alle schritte richtig
gesetzt alles richtig gemacht der
deutsche politikwissenschaftler und
journalist sebastian reinfeldt aus wien
ist da anderer meinung das motiv so spät
zu handeln so zumindest der verdacht ist
profitiert das heißt man wollte dieses
wochenende noch mitnehmen und leute so
lange wie es irgendwie möglich gibt geht
die seilbahn am laufen haben und die
betriebe offen halten
in ischgl gebe es einflussreiche
familien organisiert in der tiroler
adler runde die einfluss hat bis hoch zu
bundeskanzler kurz denn noch im februar
zu gast war bei dem gremium in tirol
sind es die mächtigen familien aus ich
gilt die sich dort das geschäft zu sagen
aufteilen und von denen auch viele
andere betriebe und personen abhängig
sind sie äußern ihre interessen ganz
direkt an den kanzler und das könnte
eine erklärung sein dafür warum
österreich trotz des wissens um die
gefährlichkeit des virus in tirol doch
relativ spät erst die maßnahmen
hochgefahren hat
sie fühlen sich als opfer einer solchen
politik die männer aus dem rheinland die
jetzt klagen wollen mit hilfe des
hamburger prozessfinanzierers jan eike
andresen
sollten die tatsächlich positive
kenntnis von den corona erkrankungen im
spiel gehabt haben und dann wider
besseren wissens nichts dagegen
unternommen haben sprechen wir
möglicherweise überfalles
körperverletzung vielleicht auch
fahrlässige
das sind straftaten und die haben für
die opfer dieser straftaten natürlich
zur folge ein anspruch auf ersatz und
auch schmerzensgeld wer ist
verantwortlich für die opfer des party
spaß in ischgl hunderte infizierte in
ganz europa und mindestens ein toter in
bochum
wenn es wirklich so ist dass die
behörden es verschwiegen haben dass
fälle aufgetreten sind und die es nicht
gemeldet haben aus welchen gründen auch
immer finanziellen gründen ist mich eine
riesen schweinerei dass das unter bogen
teppich gekehrt wurde
ischgl bergstation am morgen stille wo
sich sonst tausende osterurlauber
vergnügen
der liftbetrieb ist seit dem 13 märz
eingestellt für thomas h kam das zu spät
[Musik]